no se ha vivido una histórica jornada de
protestas y a estas horas según las
organizaciones de derechos humanos la
cifra de detenidos en todo el país
supera los tres mil también hay heridos
manifestantes y también agentes puesto
que la brutalidad que vimos ayer en las
protestas por ejemplo aquí en moscú no
la veíamos desde hacía mucho tiempo
también contemplamos escenas poco
habituales como ciudadanos rodeando y
atacando a los agentes en este caso con
bolas de nieve en medio de la calle
tanto estaba centrada la manifestación y
las movilizaciones de ayer una figura de
nava ni que aquí en moscú cuando
acabaron las protestas algunos grupos de
manifestantes marcharon hasta la prisión
de madrid y sin a dónde está preso
alexéi navalni está allí a la espera de
que un juicio decida el próximo 2 de
febrero si tiene que cumplir una nueva
condena de cárcel